are you still enjoying it the investing
part of this what we do yeah a little
bit
I had to I brought on a partner so Matt
Massey oh by the way yeah he's better at
it than I thought he mean he's better at
it quicker than I thought he'd be and so
how is he
why'd you pick him let's start there he
was at CAA right yeah so Matt was an
agent CAA he was one of the guys who
founded and ran their digital group
there he was like the first person to
sign YouTube talent you know when
everyone's like what the hell are you
doing on YouTube are you wasting your
time you had Phil DeFranco and he had
come on the cosmetics help me Oh
Michelle Phan thank you Michelle Phan he
was like her first rap and so he was his
name because he was working for Michael
at the time yeah yeah yeah over yeah
exactly and so but I met him in a jam
session at South by we just went ah deep
late one night and like Gary B's you
know why tell her I'm at the Marriott oh
it was just like a hotel room with two
queen beds that were stacked with like
20 dudes it was it was in retrospect it
was funny it was uh
Garrett camp founder of uber Travis
kalanick was there
Owen Brainerd wealth manager to the
whole you know to everyone we know Tim
Ferriss Gary Vaynerchuk and AJ and a few
other guys and then there's a msg was
there I think Michael Gumpert and then
Mazzio's was just like weasel his way in
somehow he was just incredibly well
groomed ah like manscaped action yeah
who is this guy a little too Paulo he
disputes that he was wearing a sport
coat I my memory he was that he disputes
that a camera but but what would I say
as we went into the jam such you know
what a jam sessions like it's how people
are bouncing off the walls you honor
each other and every time you open his
mouth it was smart he knew he was
talking about he knew all these company
names we'd never heard of before we were
blown away by him and I'm just like who
the hell is this guy
and so stayed in touch you know one of
his roles was to bring la type companies
up to Silicon Valley and get them
integrated here and so he was one of the
first ones to bring talent to Instagram
and just along the way I got to know him
I got to trust judgment on what was
gonna matter what wasn't I knew him as a
person how he grew up what his values
were and so I didn't run an interview
process for a partner I just called him
and made him an offer